what is a myth well a myth is a lot of
things to a lot of people but I I think
the basic way I interpret this term is
that it's a story but it's a story that
has a metaphorical Dimension so a myth
like most stories is also a metaphor and
what I mean is it's taken that way by
the audience the audience uh listening
to a fairy tale or reading a myth or
seeing a movie version of any of these
things
tends to look at it with
self-referential eye people are
profoundly self-centered and they think
everything should be about them so
they're looking for themselves in the
story or in the myth and I think the
difference between myth and story is
simply that myths have another dimension
they access us another world beyond our
normal world and this might be something
Supernatural or something uncanny it
might involve the world of fairies or
mythical creatures or the gods and the
myths tend to deal with those more
philosophical questions and almost
religious questions about why are we
here who made us how are we supposed to
align ourselves with those greater
forces than ours although I think every
story has some mythological Dimensions
to it
what is a fairy tale ah a fairy tale is
a is a specialized kind of uh story uh
sometimes you can find overlaps between
myths and fairy tales but
um I have to respect uh the scholarship
of Professor Tolkien who wrote The Lord
of the Rings books of course who was
very specific about this idea of the
world of fairy and uh said that there
there should be certain uh requirements
met or certain things need to be in the
story before we can really call it a
fairy tale and the term is used very
broadly
to incorporate things that don't have a
supernatural aspect to them but usually
it means there is some kind of
penetration of our world by another
world a world that's populated by other
kinds of spirits and creatures who have
different values and different powers
than we have
and a fairy story is a uh a story that
allows us a little light into that
darkness and uh it lets us do some
thought experiments that's how I look at
it it that it allows us to imagine what
if there was another world populated
with fairies what if there was another
world where Giants lived and where
people could fly and live forever and so
forth uh these are kind of uh
speculations that we like to put into
story form and imagine uh what what
would it be like if these things were
real
how have classic myths and fairy tales
influenced a contemporary storytelling
oh I think that the classic myths and
the fairy tales have had a huge impact
um I would say one of the strongest
vehicles for this was of course the Walt
Disney Company because Walt Disney
himself
had a certain kind of faith in the fairy
tales that there was something of value
something meaningful in them and
um he sort of elevated them
into another kind of art form when he
started doing things like Snow White
which was building on other work he had
done in short cartoons where he would
address or give you an interpretation of
some well-known fairy story but um
he really went for it with Snow White
and
um it I think alerted people to the fact
that this is a kind of a mine it's it's
a a a vein that we can access and we can
pull out of that all kinds of
entertainment uh from a comic book type
stories uh to kind like profound things
that deal with the same kind of
questions or similar setups that you
find in the fairy tales but reinterpret
it for modern audiences and sometimes
put into modern dress
that can be a very entertaining and
actually useful
aspect of of making entertainment out of
fairy tales because I think this is an
important aspect of it that
these things are useful that they were
involved they were developed and they've
been cherished in the first place
because they meant something and they
were useful to people to interpret their
own lives in comparison to
these fanciful worlds that are depicted
in myths and fairy tales so people found
something useful that they could take
back into their own ordinary everyday
lives by imagining these other worlds
and comparing uh you know what's
possible in this life and what's
possible maybe in these other imaginary
worlds and I think that's just a fun
aspect of it that people like to play
these games in their minds and uh but
are also looking all the time for some
kind of meaning out of it that applies
to me you know it's again very
self-centered people will want to know
what does it mean to me at this time in
my life and there's a lot of study
that's been done about fairy tales in uh
the arena of
looking at how the fairy tale is
interpreted at different stages of life
there's a an important writer Bruno
bettelheim who wrote a book called uses
of Enchantment which is something that
the animators at Disney I know are very
aware of and he says that fairy tales
mean different things at different times
in your life and that we're constantly
you know casually but in some kind of uh
careful way going back and looking at
them again as our perspective changes as
we age so the fairy tales have this
Evergreen aspect to them that they they
come back to us they come around again
and we see them Anew and I I think that
applies on our great domestic fairy tale
The Wizard of Oz that's one that people
get something out of as a child as a
young adult as an adult and as an older
person you look back at that story and
you can still mine out of that
valuable insights
would vampire stories or stories about
witch hunts fall into the fairy tale
realm or no because some of that is
actually based on history
well I think that when we get into the
territory of vampires and werewolves and
the various monsters and creatures
zombies and things like that
um you're in the same universe as the
fairy tales because they're populated by
all sorts of monsters and scary
creatures such as I've just mentioned
but
um there is a fascination with that
um that I think is it's akin to what
people do with the fairy tales people
are very interested in the borderline
between life and death and that's one of
the issues that comes up uh in uh horror
stories that are often dealing with the
limits of life and uh maybe suggesting
to us that these boundaries that we've
been taught may not be quite so firm and
that there may be more movement along
the scale of life and death and that's
deeply disturbing to us but it's also
fascinating and it's something that we
want to study and know more about so I
think there's a lot of focus in the
culture right now on looking at the
borderline between life and death
because it's not so sharp as it used to
be and I think people are finding you
know literature and entertainment to be
ways to explore those things
all right I think you've mentioned Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein too in the
fascination with a creature that
couldn't be contained and is grotesque
but has a life of its own and can't be
stopped kind of thing yes well
Frankenstein is an interesting case
because
um I I've always related him to uh a
kind of a teenager you know that that he
has a lot of the problems that teenagers
have his body is large and it's awkward
he doesn't know what to do with it he
feels all kinds of urges that he can't
really process and so he's going through
a kind of adolescent surge uh with all
these hormones and and other chemicals
racing around in his body
and you know he wants to be free
but you know is restricted and and can
sometimes act out in violent ways so uh
I think you know that's one way to read
stories along the line of Frankenstein
is is that we're exploring and
reflecting back always there's a mirror
in these stories that reflects back
something that we all have had to deal
with